All right. Hello. Welcome, everyone.
This is the ActInf Lab quarterly
roundtable number 20. Number two in
2022. It's June 29,
2022. So welcome to the active
inference lab. We're a participatory
online lab that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied active
coherence. You can find us at the links
on the slide. This is a recorded and an
archive Livestream, so please provide us
with feedback so we can improve our
work. All backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome and will be following video
etiquette for live streams.
Today, it's a quarterly round table lab
meeting, so we're going to have a lot of
updates to share on some of the activity
of the second quarter of 2022 and
also share a lot of next steps at the
project and at the organizational scale.
So let's begin with an introduction
warmup. We can say hello and
maybe as if it were a paper. We were
discussing what was just one memory or
something that you learned this quarter
or some participation that you just want
to call out and highlight.
So I'll go first. I'm Daniel. I'm a
researcher in California and have a
lot to add, but just saw so much amazing
parameterisation and development this
quarter without having
compiled these slides with everybody.
So much would have just it all happened
so fast and so looking forward to
catching up on this and also building
structures so that we can even have
more clarity internally and externally
about what we're working on. Like,
there's just quite a contrast with
hopefully this lab meeting and even our
previous five or six. And I'll pass it
to Bleu.
Yeah, this quarter was awesome. I think
the launch of the textbook group has
been pretty mindblowing for me. That's
like a new thing that we've done. And,
yeah, I am enjoying it and looking
forward to future cohorts. Andy Clark
two, the textbook group. But that to me
was kind of like a pivotal
moment in this last three months. And
I'll pass to Jacob. Hi, I'm Eko.
I'm a student in the UK, and the
textbook group was also the highlight
this quarter for me. And one
thing that I learned probably would
have to be that multi agent active
inference is a lot more interesting
and harder than initially means the eye.
And I'll pass it to Alex.
Yeah, thanks. I'm Alex, and I
can agree that education as
a service from the lab is the most
important thing for this quarter. So for
study group as well as for
our formers what we are planning and now
preparing for participants and more
broader community most
important thing, from deposit to Bijan.
Thank you, Alex. My name is Bijan.
I'm in Romania. I'm a researcherian,
systems management school. Last quarter
we done a lot of work
in case of education as well as
in case of administration in
the lab level. So I'm looking forward to
development for all the directions we
are dealing with. All right,
let's get into the projects. So first
we're going to provide some updates on
the project scale. So these are things
that happen during second quarter for a
variety of projects. All right,
first, as mentioned by several of us
here, we began the first cohort of
the Active Inference textbook group in
May 2022 and that will go through July
2022. And we are working on the
first five chapters of this active
inference textbook by Thomas Parr,
Giovanni Pezzulo and Karl Friston. And
just to give a little taste though,
there's a few other pieces too that
people who participate in future cohorts
will get to experience. There's a
collaborative questions and Discourse
Affordance, which has allowed people to
introduce basic clarifying questions as
well as questions about application and
about philosophy. All different kinds of
questions have been addressed in a way
that really clearly references which
part of the text it's about, which page
or which figure. And in fact, all the
tables, figures, equations and so on
have been annotated using Coda such that
by just clicking on it you can see a pop
up of a figure and that allows a very
interactive way of dealing with
different terms and different objects
of attention. And then on the right we
have some of the work by those engaged
most in the math learning, where for
each equation we are aiming to have a
natural language description. First,
just reading out the equation as it is.
And also here active coherence ontology
terms are in Bleu. So this will
facilitate the translation of equations
across human languages as well as the
development of multiple programming
languages maybe that are representing a
certain equation and giving a lot of
continuity with terms and the tools and
the points of reference within the book.
And all of that is being threaded
together really by the active inference
ontology which has been in development
since really the initial days of the
lab. So it's just awesome to see this
new knowledge artifacts come onto the
scene, new modification in the niche,
new textbook has entered the chat and
then be able to organize rapidly and
have a bunch of participants get
involved. What would anybody else like
to add about the textbook group?
It's different than a paper, it has
similarities with papers, but it is very
different. So it's been a great
experience. Anything else though? Yeah,
Alex. Yeah, I think it was also
interesting experience how Subgroup for
Math Learning was organized,
like my initiative of participants and
how it started to work on like
additional direction and provide more
energy and more efforts to structure
math side of the book.
This is our first
attempt in such activity.
As I see, it has a lot of opportunities
for learners and it helps
to acknowledge all the concepts and all
the idea of exercise.
Great. Okay, moving on to another
educational effort, the internal systems
thinking ongoing activity. Alex, would
you like to describe a little bit here?
Or.
I can say this from the beginning, it
hae Parr of our strategy to use system
thinking intelligence to organize work
on projects and it is like a
requirement for participants to have an
understanding of concepts of system
thinking. So having this computational
activity for people who are willing to
learn it and later to take part in
different roles in Labs project,
for us, it's like a
basement for all we are doing and we are
also learning. By doing visit occasion
and hopefully new version of textbook
and the program which we are using here
to help us to be more and more
efficient in all projects that we are
doing.
Any other comments here?
Yeah, we launched this type of activity
to have a common language for all
the participants and this course is
providing such language and it
is one
of such activity and
I hope we will continue with different
types of educational formats.
Great. Okay,
continuing on, we have also
in education, there was a lot of
development in Q Two with our Knowledge
Engineering and Knowledge Corpus project
Bleu. Would you like to provide initial
summary?
Sure. So I think we've described this
project before, but just briefly, we are
taking the open force papers from PubMed
that have active inference or free
energy principle as keywords. And we've
put all of these papers into a database
with all of the authors and all of the
metadata and we are
then scraping them and parsing out the
text for keywords from our ontology.
And this is shown here in the heat map,
this top right figure, it shows all the
different ontology words and how they
cluster per paper. So we've looked at
keyword clustering and authorship. Like
this is first author papers by year,
so we can kind of see trends in active
inference. But this will serve as then
a way for our ontology to access the
original data. So if you're looking for
words in the ontology, something you
don't understand, like Markov blanket or
something like this, you can actually go
straight to the horse's mouth, so to
speak, and find papers that reference
this, maybe that reference it a lot.
And so we're intending to publish this
and then really we want to build a
reflexive system and invite people to
upload their own papers. And we're also
starting to get papers from archive now.
And then we also will invite people to
upload papers that maybe are not open
access that they want to have catalog in
our database. So it's really a fun,
interesting data evidence project that
I've enjoyed working on with Daniel and
our colleague RJ. So yeah.
Just to show that heat
map again, where the columns
are the terms and the frequency of their
use and the rows are different clusters
of papers. So this is like topic
modeling, it's identifying clusters of
terms that have a similar co expression
pattern. And so it was really fun to
apply this kind of heat mapping and
clustering and some statistical
techniques because both Bleu and I have
worked with gene expression analyses
where the rows would be like the genes
and the genome and the columns would be
how much different genes are expressed
in different samples. And so the
ontology is kind of like the genome
because there's one copy of every term.
It's like a dictionary and then some
terms are used a lot or little or not at
all in any given library, in any given
sample of text. And so it's showing how
the expression of the ontology and of
terms relates to this.
In our case, a reference genome
of not just the whole language
dictionary, but specifically the active
ontology as a versioning and developing
artifact. So then rhetorical and
conceptual relationships can be drawn in
principle amongst ontology terms like
here's the relationship between Markov
Blanket and Friston Blanket or whatever
other terms are being linked and also
that can be integrated with empirical
results from the literature and also
translated across different language to
facilitate all kinds of education and
research assistance. So this will be
really fun. And as Bleu mentioned,
we're hoping to release the written
paper and the tooling around this kind
of a pipeline which includes people
being able to submit papers in annotate
and update the information and then also
have a rendering output and
hopefully we'll provide an update on
that soon. But it was a fun quarter for
this project. Any other comments
on knowledge engineering?
Okay, all right. In education
we also had a great quarter,
ActInf Livestream. So the two
main series of live streams that we had
this quarter, we had some guest dreams
and we had our regular paper discussions
live streams. So in the guest streams we
hae Parr Fatchen, Adam SAFRON, Shannon
Proch, Anna Lemke, Maxwell Ramstead
and Dalton Sakthivadivel as well as just
yesterday with professor Stephen
Grossberg. So a lot of awesome guest
dreams, one off presentations
and discussions on active inference
research really like core and cutting
edge work as well as work that might not
explicitly attention active inference
but is super consistent and of general
interest. Like with Professor Lemke, it
was a great discussion on dopamine and
in the paper, Livestream number had
paper 414-243-4445
and 46 working my way through the
was on extended active inference, 42 was
on Robotic Inclination and the Slam
Simultaneous Inclination and Mapping.
43 was a theoretical and experimental
review related to predictive coding and
active it was a mathematical review
paper 44 was
Therapeutic Alliance Active Inference
Lab the Role of Therapeutic Touch and
there Bijan Tenant was really
instrumental in coordinating those
discussions and preparing, as was Sid in
42. In 45 we talked
about free energy principle made simpler
but not too simple where Karl Friston
and Thomas Parr joined for those
discussions and provided some great
insights into this paper. And we had a
very cheerful time and there was a lot
of surprises and a lot of Bayesian
Surprise too. And no, surprise and
Bayesian Surprise are not the same thing
as we've been discussing in the
textbook. And then in the last two weeks
we've just completed Livestream number
46 on active models do not contradict
folk psychology, which was great.
Brought in some new people into live
streaming, had some conversations of
broad interest related to folk
psychology and just the way that the
academic, the lived and the DAG to DAG
perspectives on cognitive science and
experience all come together and even
uncovered some of the adjacencies there
that go into philosophical and even
biological angles. So awesome live
streams by everyone who had joined.
And yes, a lot of learning
happening within these streams.
Any other comments or things that people
want to know? Particularly fun stream
that they watched or joined?
I had so much fun in 45.1,
like, where I was deferred to as like,
the expert on the paper. It's really
funny. Like Carl's, like, well, Bleu,
what do you think? Okay,
that was really like, amusing. And cue.
Yeah, it was really a memorable
experience was beginning 45 one,
I think. And when we hit start
streaming, Bleu and I were the only
people in the chat and we didn't have
confirmation that anyone else would
join. So we just trusted
the plan and had authors join quickly.
And so it was very rapid
reduction of uncertainty and yes, as
tradition dictates the authors passing
to us. And it's that kind of like
participatory engagement where
even though they wrote the paper,
the expertise and the perspectives are
still very attributes and hopefully it's
striking a new and productive and
also value align way to talk about.
Research and to continue to develop
research after artifacts are published
in advance of other artifacts and just
hope that we can continue to integrate
in these discussions as like, the tip of
the iceberg, the best of all worlds.
In terms of having the rigor and the
clarity and the conciseness where and as
we need it, and also holding space for
everything from basic questions, things
that might not initially seem related,
everything in between. So any other
comments on live streams?
All right, we didn't talk about this
in the last quarterly lab meeting, but
this was a paper from March 1,
2022. The authors were
myself, Sean Appliquetz watson Arhan
chaudhary RJ. Coda shadi l.
Damati Abel a k.
Serval Bleu here. Yvonne here.
Sid. Sid. Code Amit Singh.
Madameth Jacob. Here. Caleb.
Tuttle and Alex. Here. So a bunch of
us and a bunch of other colleagues.
We had a great time working on this
paper. And what we did was we evaluated
web three and blockchain technology in
relationship to the emergence area of
decentralized science, DCM.
We also explored some opportunities for
where active inference could interface
with DCM in theory and in practice
as well. And that highlighted some
important conversations around DSI
in its technological aspects. What kind
of technology is composing or moving the
frontier of DCM in 2022 and
then more in principle, what does it
mean for science to be decentralized?
Decentralized in what way? Wasn't it
always decentralized? What kinds of
failure modes across multiple scales do
decentralized systems present themselves
with? So we in the first part of this
paper evaluated decentralized science
DCM and just covered some historical
threads that a lot of the coauthors just
shared amazing views on. We then
presented an Active Entity Biology for
Science or AOS and presented
it in Coda of tables, but we'll talk
more about how we're continuing to
develop it. It is a composable and
versionable modeling system that uses
the active inference entity partition
with the blankets and the same ontology
terms that we would use to describe
particular entities partitioned states
like affordances and policies and so on.
And separated types of entities
into two main types active entities,
which are like adaptive active entities
that are able to undertake actions and
modify their niche and informational
entities, which are also partitioned
entities but do not engage in action
selection. So, like a PDF of a paper,
it's an informational entity, it's in
the epistemic niche, but it's not taking
actions. Whereas active entities ranging
from humans or programs as well
as organizational institutional type
entities across multiple scales are
engaging in communication and actions
around their epistemic niche.
That is providing a foundation and a
grounding for continued discussions that
we're having about how to bring
integrity and continuity amongst natural
language representations, visual
representations, and simulation type
representations of complex digital and
cyber physical systems. So would any of
the other authors like to share, like
anything that I missed or one part about
this paper that they found useful or
interesting to work on?
So I'll share. I thought this paper was
interesting because there was a or there
is quite a bit of tension between
decentralization in terms of distributed
effort and labor and also DCM as
a market based entity or idea.
And so resolving these two
things or like the tension and
juxtaposition of what is decided, is it
just the distribution of knowledge and
resources or is it more based on markets
and blockchain? I think that was one of
the key insights brought upon by this
paper. Yes.
And hopefully we'll have more spaces and
time to explore and draw out some of
these threads, maybe even a guest stream
with these authors. But what
is today known as Web Three and
blockchain is developing and growing out
of and beyond financial technology.
And perhaps there's a sense of an
agreement in which financial technology
are some of the sinews and connective
tissues by which science occurs,
like value and financial action
occur in scientific and epistemic
ecosystems. But is that the common
denominator? Will we be financial
reductionists with respect to how we
model, for example, motivation and all
these types of cognitive features in
epistemic ecosystems? At the same
time, there's many features of
blockchain systems that make them a
natural fit for scientific information.
So it's an ongoing discussion, and
hopefully those with interest in DCM or
in these kinds of technologies overall
will just stay tuned and get involved
because we're just beginning this avenue
of development. Okay, any comments here?
Or we'll continue.
Okay, next we'll talk about some
research and applications. We'll talk
about the active Block Force project.
So, Jacob, do you want to provide a
little summary of active blockfronts?
Yeah. So active Blockchains is
foraging progress Python package that
concepts the recent
new library for modeling
agent with active inference called
Time DP, and another library called
Catcat, which is used a lot in economic
and complex system simulations. So
Active Ballard is right now a
combination of the two where active
imprint agents are
modeled within Catcad and
currently still very much work in
progress. The overall structure of the
package is still being developed, and
we're working on polishing
the implementation of Time DP and
tailoring it more towards the Catcat
style of development and also working on
problems how to increase
the complexity of the models with like,
multiagine modeling or different
constraints.
Thanks. So Pymdp, just for context,
is a Python package that
has recently been developed, and it
provides a very simplified
foothold for Python programming to be
implementing the kinds of Markov
decision processes that's MDP that are
used in some formulations of active
inference. And so it's an incredibly
important package to use. And also
there are some other features that are
requisite to use for systems engineering
for the kinds of generative models and
generative process that we might want to
implement in real applied active
coherence settings. For example,
parameter brain architectures and being
able to specify execution orders and
have some reproducibility around certain
kinds of simulations, various features
that the CAD CAD framework provides for.
So as Jakob mentioned at the very
beginning, the multiagent case is quite
interesting. Like, does each entity
perceive and then act and then we
cascade through them in the same order,
different order, or is there some other
structures and execution orders? How
does that influence active inference
simulations? With Metamath, I've been
continuing to work on the next
generative model, the active infraant
Colony implication, so I hope to share
more specifics when we have it. But this
is a continuation of the work that was
done in 2021 with several colleagues.
We're working on various other aspects
of the package, and this last one here
connecting to Ethereum or other Web
three ecosystems. So just to kind of
hinge on that and Clark into the next
slide. For the Active Blueprint project,
there was an Ecosystem Support Program
grant available from the Ethereum
Foundation, and we proposed in a grant
application about a month ago to expand
our current simulations into multi agent
setting in order to explore cognition
and behavior underlying DCM and D five
projects. The grant was not funded, so
the foraging continuum but it was a
great learning experience and it helped
us sharpen and elaborate
on everything from the substance of the
package itself to the Communications
around it, and have preliminary
discussions on how do we balance in a
distributed team, retroactive funding,
proactive funding, and so on.
Specifically, we were proposing to
develop multi agent ant, some case
studies and digital twins that already
exist in the ethereum ecosystem,
porting those over into Active
coherence lab framework and
helping characterize scenarios and
phenomena that had previously been only
approached from a top down, essentially
macroeconomic type of simulation.
Like if the interest rate is this amount
and this is the other parameter on this
macro, then here's how the system will
evolve. Trying to coherent that with a
bottom up cognitive entity decision
making framework that could be used in a
lot of interesting ways. Specifically,
we were interested about the
possibility, and still are, of
performing these kinds of cognitive
audits, which is a terminology used in
various artificial intelligence Fields.
But a cognitive audit could provide
insights into if potentially there was
some smart contract or series of cyber
physical relationships where from a
computer security or network security
perspective, it was airtight.
However, in the cognitive niche,
perhaps there were destabilizing forces
or dynamics. And although it wouldn't
have been part of our initial work, we
hope to eventually include cognitive
features even like for example,
narrative and sentiment, such that
different kinds of information, natural
language, reading and writing, all these
kinds of features of real cognitive
systems could be integrated into these
increasingly actionable and coherent
digital twin type simulations. So if
anybody is interested to get more
involved in Active blockprints, whether
they have familiarity with Python,
Cadcad Academy, all or none of the
above, everybody is welcome to get
involved. And also, if anyone has
insights into how such a project might
receive some funding, we're also open to
those thoughts. Anything else on the
grant application?
Okay, we on the engagement and outreach
frontier continuum,
connecting with new and returning
participants on different platforms. We
saw growth across our Discord Twitter
podcast channel and YouTube channel,
so it was a good
quarter of activity on these fronts.
And of course, always feel free to share
our public information or invite other
people who you think might want to get
involved. But we continue with the work.
And these are our Active states in the
epistemic niche. Any funny
tweets, any memorable emojis?
Okay? And then closing
out the project updates on the staying
on the engagement in outreach theme,
we have some directions that
are coalescing relating to the
engagement and outreach at Active. So
first we are developing an internship
program that will share more details on,
but will provide a much more scaffolded
project specific way for individuals who
want to on ramp into the lab or to step
up their activity and learn by doing
that way. We've written some letters of
support for applications at university
programs with more information. Should
these applications of our colleagues
be accepted? We believe that this kind
of institution to institution
partnership is going to be, there's
going to be a lot of affordances for win
win opportunities with different
institutions reaching out to active lab
and having a relationship where we can
each contribute what we can do and be
part of some joint action and
generalized synchrony. And also
especially through the relentless work
of Dave Douglas, we've been improving
our subtitles and language translation
progress which we'll talk more about.
But language translation includes math.
So just at this first pass it's raising
attention to the way in which whether
it's audio content or textual content or
morphing in between with speech to text
and TextToSpeech annotation and
translation is the basis of rigorous
scholarship as well as accessible
information. So making sure that
whatever the initial artifact is that it
can be consumed and enjoyed in the
sensory modality that's most accessible
to a given person and translated into
the natural language, computer languages
and so on that are most familiar to
somebody, again, also helps with
accessibility and rigor. So just like we
looked at with a textbook group, with
the math as a language truly being
translated into natural language, using
ontology terms that will facilitate
translations amongst different
languages, that will just make sure that
from the first step to the 99th step
of learning and applying active
inference that it's really coherent and
a comprehensive experience. So really
awesome directions. And if anyone sees
opportunities to join in engagement
and outreach with us, of course, please
feel free to just contact us.
Any other comments on project updates on
this action?
Okay, so the next section of this lab
meeting will be about the next steps at
the project scale,
starting with the theme of education.
As mentioned, we are completing the
first cohort first part of the active
textbook group. After Cohort Hae,
Park One will finish up through Chapter
Five. In the end of July we're going to
take August off and then we are going to
pick back up with two parallel cohorts.
There's going to be cohort one
continuing on with part two of the
textbook so that those first Conor can
finish the textbook, at least a first
pass on it during 2022. We will
then also begin cohort two of part
one. So these will be a totally new
batch of people who are coming in and
starting on chapter one and people
from cohort one who want to just take a
second pass. I think we all do
in a sense. Whether we take the plunge
to be in cohort two or not is a
different question. But all these
materials are the kinds of things that
we can just get many coats of, paint on
and learn and read again and again.
We're really excited for this second
cohort because we'll be incorporating a
lot of what we're learning from the
first Conor into how we proceed with
this second cohort as well as
with part two in the first cohort.
And hopefully this is just the first few
of many, many textbook group cohorts
because it provides a very accessible on
ramp into learning and applying active
coherence. The textbook is written with
that kind of learning and applying in
mind and hopefully these textbook
groups are providing a service that
makes that onramp even smoother and more
fun and with more image memes and with
more connecting the dots and more
exercises to test more opportunities to
ask questions. And I'll put the
link in the YouTube chat for registering
to participate in an upcoming cohort.
Does anyone else want to add anything
about this next steps on the textbook
group?
Just that it's a great opportunity to
get involved if you ant to learn more
about active coherence or even if you're
starting at ground zero. We've had some
people come in with no idea about the
math and yeah it's been I think really
useful to work with everyone from all
levels to kind of try to make this field
more accessible for you.
Awesome. Okay.
Also on the education theme
as suggested in some of the
updates we're learning a lot from the
textbook group and other educational
projects that are occurring in the lab
like the active inference ontology
development and livestreams and with
education and research as our mission
we've always been interested in
developing some active inference courses
and educational experiences.
Alex, do you want to provide some
updates on how we'll be continuing here?
Yeah, thanks.
This activity on creating online course
is also many hours learning
by doing force our own for creating
courses because we understand that for
different audiences different courses
need to be created and finally we should
have like a bunch of different ones
and this introductory course
will be and example of organizing the
team of different educational roles
which understand the needed to take part
of creating course which should be
quality, have quality and have
accessibility and so on. That's why
based on experience and materials and
results of textbook group including
and developing different types of cases
and examples into online form which
can be supported by online platform
which we'll be using from Systems
Management School it will be the first
step to broad set
of educational materials for any
new people who will start to learn
active coherence and we will create
courses and improve it.
Improved set of courses to make it
accessible to as much people as
possible. Yes, in the
long arc of education and
even just active inference education.
This is a modified curio card.
Yes, I right click saved it and now on
the top of this pile of books is the
active inference textbook and it's just
reflecting like one more epistemic niche
modification and it is coming
after of course many papers and also
other kinds of educational materials
that have been prepared foraging from
short form workshops. That have been
held in different locations to blogs and
GitHub repositories like famously ant
Beren Millidge of just informative
links. And those are all very important
educational formats. However,
there is nothing like an active
inference course. And for a course to be
done right and versioned in our
attention situation and with
our conceptual focus on active
inference, it's quite a challenge. But
there's also an amazing opportunity
here. So for those who would like to be
learning more about how to participate,
this is one way to be getting
involved at some stage with a team
or with feedback on the initial course.
Or of course, just as with the textbook
group, the early cohorts who cocreate in
this participatory way. So this is super
exciting. And also we've had a lot of
great contributions from participants
from Dean Jessica Brock,
so many others who've added and helped
us build a lot of like
a garage of spare parts and motifs
and conversation that when we formalize
the course, team will be able to be
taken into account and implemented.
Okay. Alright.
On the education theme as well, let's
talk about the systems thinking summer
intensive. Yvonne or Alex, want to
describe what will be happening in
August 22?
Yes, in August we will launch a
branch active States Thinking course and
it will unpack the
base concepts of the system. One of the
base concepts system thinking, It's
roles and role based
descriptions.
For four weeks we
will define what the roles are,
how we can use it to have
common meaning with how
we can see different things in
a way to understand each other.
Yeah, that's it.
Great. Alex, anything?
Okay. All right. So in
educational activities, we are
announcing some of the early sketching
around the internship program, which
perhaps by any other name would it smell
so sweet. It's really like a learning by
doing scaffolded affordance. It is a
selfdriven opportunity for individuals
of all ages, entorhinal states,
backgrounds, etc. To engage in personal
learning and development that will be
related in a large part to project based
contributions to ActInf lab. So it'll be
win win. You'll be learning by doing and
contributing to the lab as well and
helping projects develop the
duration and time commitment. We're
figuring out some details, but will be
able to make it work for people who want
to be involved. We'll find a way to make
it happen. For those who engage
in this type of internship,
beyond the priceless value of
learning and development and being
on the trajectory of active inference,
serving the lab can also offer
everything from letters of
recommendation and evidence and
mentorship, as well as increased access
to the digital research architectures of
the lab. And we also hope to provide
more affordances as we gain resources
and organizational complexity. And these
internships will be centered around a
target project, although there will also
be curriculum of the internship that is
not related to a project like related to
watching live streams or engaging in the
textbook group cohorts. But a lot of the
contribution will be focused on a
project that will be carried out in a
structured way, so it'll provide again
great opportunities for people who have
skills that they would like to apply,
skills they'd like to learn. For now,
the best way to learn more about this
internship, whether you're interested or
whether you know of somebody who might
like to maybe get involved, would be
to contact us, active
coherence@gmail.com and or to
register for the systems thinking summer
intensive, because these projects will
have role based approaches to
participating. So the Summer intensive
is a couple weeks long, couple of hours
per week, and it will provide a nice
warm up for getting involved in a role
based internship program.
Okay, any other thoughts here?
Okay, also in our next steps,
we are expanding and scaling the active
inference journal. So this is again
work with several participants and
especially Dave. We've been preparing
a sequence of work and practices and
roles so that for our past catalog
of live streams and other presentations
and going forward we will be able to
have a effective and automatable and
also just documentable. And reproducible
approach for preparing the transcript
of a speech event into an edited,
curated format that can then be rendered
into, on one hand, a prose based format
which can be published for indexing,
citing and searching and on the other
hand, into a subtitle format that will
facilitate accessibility of the videos
and also that can all be translated
across different languages. So it'll be
really exciting to really nail down
our practices and ways of working
such that within several days,
potentially after a live stream
occurring, we could publish a very high
quality annotated artifact
that could leverage the impact of a lot
of these very important conversations
that are happening and anything
else to add on the journal.
All right,
we will announce here that
we are having a second applied active
inference symposium on the theme of
robotics. It will be held on July 31,
2022, from four to eight and
16 to 20 UTC. So all the
dates and times are UTC. It's a four
hour first interval, twelve hour break,
or sorry, eight hour break,
and then another four hour entorhinal
states tuned on social media in our
newsletter for more information,
including presenters. We've been having
a great time collaborating with
coorganizers Matt Brown and Mark Miller,
as well as some of us on this call.
And in the last year or two, there have
just been many important introduction
works bridging, active inference and
robotics. So for example, here's an
image from how active coherence could
revolutionize robotics DA Costa, Ant all
recently, as well as the paper that we
discussed of Data et al. In April in
Livestream 42 on the simultaneous
localization and mapping. So we hope to
hold this symposium where there will be
presentations and roundtable type
discussions that are live streamed as
well as recorded and rewatchable, and
also with transcripts that will be
published as proceedings to highlight
some issues and opportunities in this
increasingly important area of active
inference and robotics. So we hope to be
drawing on many perspectives, those who
are coming at the active robotics
intersection from the perspective of
researchers, industries involved in
robotics or active inference, those with
curiosity, those with philosophical
interest in these topics, ethics, and
the social implications. There's going
to be a lot of great discussions around
this symposium, so just stay tuned and
we'll have more information coming out
soon. Any other comments on the
symposium or any other next steps for
projects?
Okay, so one new thing,
special announcement time.
As of June 2022 this month,
we are formalizing a transformation at
the organizational scale from the active
coherence lab into the active active
inference institute.
Use those emojis, but this has been a
really exciting development and we like
to just share a little bit about it now.
We've been working with Fried Frank in
pro bono law firm Capacity and they've
been helping guide this developmental
process. We're initiating
some enterprise architecture development
such as updating and improving our
governance structure, obtaining funding
and hiring for research and educational
roles, and identification of focal
projects as affordances for encoding.
More generally. This move in
generative models or Markov blanket from
the active lab to the active coherence
institute helps us clarify and continue
on with our strategy around education
and research. And the time has
come for something different and bigger.
And so we hope that the AI organization
will be able to represent that and
scaffold that and provide those services
to our niche in the best possible way.
I guess there's a ton to share and ask
and in the coming few slides we'll talk
a little bit about strategy. But what do
people want to and here about this just
for now.
I want to say that these changes on
organizational scale from one hand
reflects the growing number of services
that we are providing to the niche and
from the other hand is an answer for
growing complexity of activities. And I
believe that after we're analyzing
immigration projects before
the beginning of next semester,
we will be really ready for scaling
of our activities and to include more
people to participate and having that
scale to the opportunity
to grow and having to
grow with new skills
and having new possibly
group departments and different types of
projects and support different types of
collaborations. Thanks.
Anyone else want to add before we talk
about strategy a little bit?
You just want to Bleu, please. I just
wanted to add that I don't know, it's
really involved process becoming
a 503 C and thinking about governance
structure and how that fits into our
strategy and balancing the things we
have to do like obligational
commitments. In order to further the
success of the active inference
institute and also the fun things that
we like to do, like research and papers
and textbook groups and things like
that. So striking a balance has been
interesting, challenging, and hopefully
it'll be rewarding.
Yes, it's only 18
months ago when we began a lot
in the beginning of 2021,
and we very immediately afterwards
began the process of foraging as a
nonprofit. We did end up doing that in a
California nonprofit and that
was a good
step that helped us get a taste of the
kinds of enterprise architecture that we
would ultimately need. And now we're
ready to face those challenges and
opportunities really directly with this
new approach. So it's super exciting and
we just wanted to include it in this lab
meeting as recent developments and more
will be coming in the coming months.
In July of 22, we'll take kind of a
summer break. There won't be any live
stream paper discussions, and during
that time we'll be having
a lot of migrations and updates.
So just stay tuned for things to be
updating as they do in the Act
Institute. Let's talk a little bit about
strategy. So here we'll present a update
on our strategy, documents that as
we update this at the Cordially scale,
we'll be helping to guide some of the
next development steps in active
Institute. So, Active Inference
Institute AI, or you can use Emojis with
just an A and then the two I. Emoji is
on the path of openendedness. Our
strategy considers learning and applying
active inference for changes in the
niche over multiple nested scales.
Through time, we increase the degree of
hierarchical communication complexity to
overcome competing interactions and
frustrated states. We engage in policy
selection, reducing our uncertainty
about realizing our expectations and
preferences for epistemic value values
as a nonprofit organization. At the same
time, to ensure Institute development,
we need to secure pragmatic financial
sustainability with enabling activity.
And the three scales that the AII is
modifying and interacting with are
first, the participant as an agent, the
human participant. The Institute
provides affordances and updates
participants generative models via
providing them a modified niche with
the Institute as an agent. This level
is where we can engage in Institutelevel
policy selection and evolve a shared
generative model that goes beyond any
one participant. And then lastly,
we are modifying and interacting with
our communities and peer organizations
in our epistemic niche, where we provide
services and opportunities and engage in
collaborations with community. So, any
overall thoughts on this?
Okay, to our
first area of focus. Thank you,
Bleu.
Our first area of focus is education.
At the participant's scale, we approach
the participants active inference
mastery as the system of interest to
reflect the plurality of individual
priors expertise levels and preferences.
We develop different educational formats
such as workshops, discussion groups,
online courses, project based learning,
internships, and more. And our
preference is to have up to a hundred
participants involved in education by
the end of 2022 at the
Institute scale, we're learning
StateoftheART ways of working and
practices across functional domains to
build and strengthen our organizational
capacities. And at the Community Scale,
we work on education and reducing
research debt for broad communities.
We develop public video and audio
content that spreads, and we prefer
to reach out to many dozens of thousands
of people with the information that we
create. Any other like thoughts
or ideas on education?
I think it's exciting to explore what
the future and the present of education
are. We've seen only the early
days of online education,
even though there's been many effective
or less effective approaches tried.
There's so much to
develop around how we educate,
especially for active inference lab area
two related to research at the
participant scale, we provide
affordances to scaffold and launch
research and development projects by
participants. Projects can be driven by
participants inside or outside of our
organization, and the Institute will
provide relevant support. We expect to
see dozens of research outcomes in the
coming months and years, ranging from
papers, workshops and conference
presentations and from the basic to the
applied. At the Institute scale,
as an organization, we rearrange, we
catalyze and participate in active
inference research projects with long
term impact or public goods features
like ontology development, knowledge
engineering, and also events such as
symposiums and conferences. At the
Community scale, we recognize and seek
to carry out, apply and improve upon
research practices from open science,
DCM, beyond,
so to be caught up education,
D school and then to go beyond and
create novelty and discover on the
frontier research like DSI.
Those are the two key and first focuses
of the active Institute. The third is
outreach and engagement. So at the
participants scale, we think of
participants as ambassadors of the
Institute, so we welcome and support
their initiatives to share a voice about
active inference in various situations
and communities. At the Institute scale,
we aim to set up partnerships with other
organizations from academia, industry
and beyond. This supports high quality
science communication education and
collaborations around research topics
such as active inference. And at the
Community scale, we acknowledge the
diversity of people's initial cognition
for example, their familiarity with
different languages, science,
philosophy, computation, everything.
We develop projects like the active
Coherence online journal and create
popular science content for different
social media. And we hope to provide
portfolio of outreach and engagement
opportunities again to meet those who
are interested where and how they are.
Any other thoughts or ideas on this?
So, just a thought on the research
strategy for people that might have
projects that didn't start in the active
inference lab or projects that they want
to start and haven't yet started. We
don't necessarily start projects.
Sometimes projects come to us. So if
you're looking for a network of people
or maybe weekly meetings with feedback
or something else to scaffold your
project, we can provide access to a big
community of active inference
researchers and like would welcome
projects that have already taken off.
So if you have a project that you want
to bring into the lab that is open
science that's I think one of the key
things force the lab, we would just
welcome that opportunity to work with
anyone who wants to do active inference
lab based project. Thanks Lou. And yeah,
hopefully we can have more exemplars and
clear lanes and the
mystery lanes for those that don't even
yet exist. But there's a continuum of
ways to participate in project based
learning ranging from coming to
an Act Institute scaffolded project
where we will help with the rhythm, the
infrastructure, the role assignment and
everything. It's kind of like a show up
and enter the game type project.
There also might be projects that are
totally off the radar of Act Institute.
It's just you are participating in a
project or not, but you're connecting
with participants in the organization
and you find a latent interest and you
collaborate that way with your own font,
formal documents, ontologies narratives
and tools or something in the middle
where you have a project that's at a
stage where you're ready to get feedback
from the active inference community or
just from any interested people. Maybe
there's opportunities to collaborate or
maybe you're looking for just some help
on tweaking it and fine tuning it as you
prepare, for example, to submit a paper
or develop the next version of
something. So there's so many ways to do
research and education that we will
just have clarity around where is
the projects that the institute is
scaffolding and moving the needle on.
And those are the kind of massively
collaborative projects where people who
want to be involved can kind of get
involved and check back in and out all
the way to projects that are self driven
and you're seeing the lab as again a
niche that is modified for you to
support those kinds of research efforts.
Like one exciting opportunity there is
for individuals who would like to be
writing or building applications that
use active inference to gain some
familiarity with the ontology. Could go
a long way, and somebody could just hang
out in the relevant meetings or read the
relevant documents and publications.
And then that is like a way to close the
feedback loop and to use these services
that are being provided in the niche,
like the ontology. And so reduce
research debt by promoting coherent
and comprehensive use of active
inference terms and concepts. And so
there's many ways to learn and research
and apply aligned with this overview
strategy, work and progress we're
presenting here. And lastly four
methods. At the participant scale,
we educate participants so they grow
their expertise level in different
disciplines as disciplinary expertise
entails competency in various practices
and tools. We take a holistic approach
to participant professional development
at the Institute scale, communication
and organizational design our
fundamental effort. We apply active
inference systems thinking and other
first principles approaches to the
institute operations and at the
community scale we share and promote
methods we use throughout the community
to increase the quality and efficiency
of collaborations and we're also open to
recommendations for new methods and
strategies to consider.
So methods is a little bit of the how
just as if it were a scientific paper
and the what is education,
research, outreach and engagement.
So this lab meeting has consisted
a little bit of and introduction
section. Again sticking with this
scientific paper metaphor, an
introduction of updates maybe also
those are our results, some discussions
and next steps. And now
with this one new thing we are
also pointing the way in which
we are heading during this ongoing
transformation into the Active Inference
Institute. It's a really exciting
time for those who are involved
in paying attention. We expect and
prefer and there's many
opportunities to be getting more
involved in any number of ways ranging
from educational opportunities to
joining the kinds of projects where you
can be engaged in research, education,
development, application.
Many opportunities there and it's
just the beginning for the institute.
So much more will be happening
as time flies.
What else would people like to address
or ask or bring up? In closing.
I want to say that results and plans
that we're having reflects our
initiatives in a really long time scale
and we understand that we can evaluate
results like in one or two decades and
say that this first initial small steps
Beren like a beginning on something
big. And as for strategy and
all that we have now is like
applications of approaches that we chose
in the beginning and an example of
strategy, which is like a process for
us. And that updates on quarterly
base updates. Of the strategy is
important because it provides a way to
be adaptive and react on changes, on
information we are getting in the
process of work and also consideration
an institute. And the strategy on at
least three scales that we
are paying attention to and planning
changes for free scales is also
providing to us a lot of opportunities
to affect different aspects
and niches which are related.
And that's why being on one hand
have a very long time horizontal in our
planning and ant the same time
having very flexible approach to
development like this cornerstone
of false principles and kind of
evolution and open ended approach I
believe will bring us very
interesting results advanced.
Does anyone else want to add anything or
I'll make a note we can continue
discussing.
So one conversation that Jacob and
I and others were kind of developing and
meming out over the quarter was like
what if active inference only works for
like one or two times steps.
And as we consider deeper and deeper,
even potentially two in the most extreme
versions of the meme that the
combinatorics of decision making in
principle and or in practice become
challenging to evaluate and compute
like the computational complexity grows
potentially extremely rapidly
considering even two moves deep, so to
speak. We've seen several approaches
to dealing with this. First is the
continuous time approximation of active
inference where there is no explicit
time series prediction of future time
points. There's just like a Taylor
series approximation based upon the
generalized coordinates of motion.
Other approaches we've seen are deep
active inference, just rolling out that
prediction to deeper and deeper time
points anyway, and then utilizing
heuristics and other algorithmic
approaches to ameliorate that
combinatoric. And we've also seen
sophisticated or hierarchical active
inference modeling where potentially at
two or more hierarchical model scales of
the model, still only one or two time
points or only a few time points have to
be reflected. So it would be like to
predict out 100 years. One could have a
model with a temporal depth of 100, or
there could be ten time
points, each consisting of a decade of
ten years. And so then that could even
be broken down further. And so
when Alex was talking about the way in
which there's an imperative to
act in an adaptive way to
not die and to live and to thrive and to
serve, of course, but in many
cases there are some challenges
associated with decision making. We
don't have the ability to do a B testing
or null hypothesis or even just
alternatives over very long time scales,
over certain levels of organization. It
might be possible to do for an agent
that's rapid or has a lot of individuals
engaging with it, like a website. A B
testing might work super well if 100
people are looking at the website every
day, whereas in organizational design
there isn't that much of the same
affordance. And it speaks to the
way in which our multiple nested
timescales of updating hopefully
provide clarity so that we don't need to
be at the fast cycle trying to predict
out 100 years. But with increasingly
deep hierarchical temporal models, we
might be able to act adaptive in a
multiscale way. So, for example, in 2021
we were planning heavily on the quarter
timescale we introduction and assembled
our scientific advisory board which
began operating in 2022. And that was
explicitly after one year of operations,
expanding our temporal horizon to the
one year time scale. Now,
with the Kind brain architectures
updates that the Act Institute is
providing and necessitating, we're
thinking beyond one year explicitly
because questions like who can elect who
in the organization? They do play out
over slower and slower time scales.
So it's Beren quite interesting,
even mostly qualitatively, to be
applying and transferring what we're
learning about multi scale decision
making under uncertainty from active
inference, which is kind of what it's
about, and apply it in the
organizational multiscale context with a
participant in the projects and teams
and the institute scale and the
community in the niche scale. And so
it's already been very rewarding and
we hope effective to,
in a principled way,
bring our learnings and ideas about
organizational design and the vast
emergence that so many participants do
bring to the table on these issues.
And coordinate around carrying
that out in the active inference
ontology in a sense, and using other
pieces of the puzzle that aren't now or
in the future even necessarily part of
the active inference biology. A lot of
those features we derive from systems
thinking. Active inference isn't a
project management approach so there's
going to have to be like more than just
the active ontology to carry out
effective team management. But that's
why we use multiple ways of learning
and researching. So it just was
very interesting how some of the
theoretical discussions that we were
having literally about multiscale
planning in multiagent active
simulations and the kind of cognitive
complexity that needs to happen on board
the entity, what is their actual
cognitive complexity and awareness and
affordances versus how are we going to
simulate it? How do we prevent the
simulation from, like, sneaking in extra
indoctrination? How do we think about
the role of stigma and the modifications
of the niche and the cognitive
offloading that could happen in a
multiagent setting or in a stigmergic
context that is in tight
feedback with the ways in
which we're also structuring our own
niche. And a lot of that
really started to take an acceleration
point in the last several months with
Jacob's contribution of active lock
friends and other individuals
contributions and the seeds were
planted in the work even before active
lab existed. With Violkin it all 2020
active coherence lab and behavior
engineering and systems thinking and
remote teams. So it is
a long game,
but then long compared to what? It's
just the game it is. And multiscale
decision making with diverse
perspectives over multiple spatial and
temporal scales are not like the end
point or some hot take that is our
starting point for planning as
inference. And I hope
that all these threads can just continue
to develop over the timescales that are
appropriate and that we can connect with
participants who are interested
or those who see that high quality
engagement and relationship building and
development are worthwhile in
terms of epistemic and pragmatic value.
And sometimes that takes multiple years
to approach this exciting and developing
topic which is changing month by month
as our guest dreams just recently have
been highlighting. So for those who
feel uncertain about participating,
they feel some impulse to get involved
now watching Livestream or in the
future. Yes, it's easy and absolutely
valid to feel busy and like it's
an affordance that's not immediately
preferable and I'm not saying drop
everything and join Act Institute.
However, again, we hope that those who
have paid attention to what we've shared
today and hopefully continue to share
and for those who resonate with the
approach that we're taking, adaptively
resonate with the strategic vision
and with the increasingly clear and
numerous affordances for learning and
researching. We hope to connect with you
individuals and create services
that scale even beyond those who get
very active in the Institute itself.
And so much more is
to come. Again, it has been quite a ride
in the last six quarters, and people can
check our quarterly round table
meetings, which are slides
being modified up to the day,
basically, and they're like an
honest representation of how things are
developing. Our uncertainties around
different developments in the lab.
We have nothing if not honesty and
clarity and vision, so there's
no clean way to end it when one has
walked this deep down the Planck. But
I'll just, again, you know, appreciate
everyone who's helped in every way
to get us to this point. From the people
who, like, first were enthusiastic about
the idea of active inference Lab lab in
the beginning of 2021. And end of 2020,
more than a year before the textbook,
when it was, and still, to some extent,
is, an assemblage of papers
with partially overlapping focus and
ontology uses and notation. And amidst
that uncertainty, some people did
step up, and they acted, and they
inferred and they served. And now we're
starting another chapter, and the
logo doesn't change, and everything else
is just continuing to develop. So it's
been a great ride, and thanks again to
everybody who, even as just a listener
for now, has been involved in some way
in really being a part of the embodiment
and the action of ActInf activinstitute.
So just expect and prefer epistemic
and pragmatic value, and may
the gradient be with you.
Any last comments? Or we can end it
there?
Okay, thank you, fellows. See you later.
Bye. Thank you.